i want to take this moment to share
something very personal with you
over the past year and a half i've been
doing some healing and self-reflective
work
and through this work i've had the
revelation that i identify as non-binary
demi lovato is opening up about their
identity
i focus on just what i see in the mirror
and that's
a beautiful person the 28 year old pop
star debuted their new podcast 4d with
demi lovato which dropped at midnight on
wednesday
and said they are changing their
pronouns i'll officially be changing my
pronouns to they them
i feel that this best represents the
fluidity i feel in my gender expression
and allows me to feel most authentic and
true to the person i both know i
am and still am discovering the
performer also added
this disclaimer i want to make it clear
that i'm still learning and coming into
myself
and i don't claim to be an expert or a
spokesperson
i will also be accepting
[Music]
if people slip and say
hershey because i know that
being in my position it's going to take
a while for people to get
used to i just want them to be making
the effort
demi invited non-binary performance
artist elope on their show
noting that one of alok's poetry shows
which they attended with musician sam
smith
who also identifies as non-binary helped
inspire demi's personal discovery
it was the first time in so long that
i've ever
heard someone else speak my truth
and then realize oh that's my truth too
and for anyone who might not be familiar
with the term non-binary
eloque offered some insight we are
people who have existed for thousands of
years
who actually experience ourselves
outside of the idea of man or woman
demi added that their identity has
nothing to do with how they choose to
dress
or quote present themselves i want
people to understand that just because
i'm non-binary doesn't mean
i'm not going to
dress the way i want the singer who has
been an outspoken lgbtqia plus advocate
and
ally for many years says they are aware
of the backlash they may receive after
this announcement
and when alok pointed out that haters
could claim demi was sharing this news
for attention
or to further their career demi had this
to say
i could leave my career today
i'm still going to identify as
non-binary tomorrow
for the first time in my life i'm
putting my well-being over my career
that's the difference in somebody i
guess doing something for attention and
like
versus speaking your truth is i know
that not everybody is going to love
that this is me and this is my truth i
know that people are going to react out
of fear
the 28 year old who has been open about
their struggles with addiction
and substance abuse said that the lack
of authenticity in their identity
led to their 2018 overdose in 2018
when i overdosed i feel like the reason
why that happened was because i was
ignoring my truth
and i was suppressing who i really am
in order to please stylists or
team members or this or that or even
fans that wanted me to be
the sexy feminine pop star in the in the
leotard and look a certain way you know
i thought that was what i was supposed
to be
and now i just realize it's so much more
important to live your truth
than to ever suppress yourself because
that's the type of stuff that happens
when you do
demi also referenced their 2020
short-lived engagement to actor max
eric which ended after two months
got engaged to a dude
and was like okay maybe this is maybe
this is it you know and
i it still didn't feel right and i knew
when things didn't work out i knew why
it didn't feel right it's because i
wasn't being myself
following their announcement glaad
released a statement supporting the star
and praised their work within the
community quote demi has always been one
of the loudest
and proudest advocates for lgbtq people
and issues in sharing their story today
they
will educate countless people around the
world and reach
other non-binary people with a message
of pride
you